sur ce site plus de 100 ans d'histoire
mécanique de l'armée française chars
camions véhicules blindés les plus
récents sont encore en service d'autres
sont entrés dans les mémoires comme ce
poids lourds inusable ce camion c'est un
camion cba de berliet qui est née au
début de la première guerre mondiale et
qui a été le héros de la voie sacrée qui
permettait de profiter les troupes à
verre dans des engins longtemps utilisé
sur les terrains d'opération est devenu
pièces de collection ce sont des
véhicules qui étaient en service dans
l'armée française beaucoup trop mer mais
aussi dans de nombreuses armées
africaines là il s'agit de duvet lra
dons et prêts de collectionneurs et de
musées constitue une partie du fonds le
reste provient directement du groupe
arcus héritiers de plusieurs grands
constructeurs du secteur de la défense
on a réalisé qu'on avait sur nos
parkings du sinn puisqu'on a quatre
usines production des engins des engins
blindés à roues qui qui aurait pu être
détruit si on n'avait pas fait quelques
jours garchizy n'a pas été choisi au
hasard ici l'entreprise assure la
maintenance de véhicules militaires gère
les pièces détachées pour l'armée
française partout dans le monde
400 emplois qui incarne le présent et le
futur du site issu de ce patrimoine
il ya un très fort attachement au passé
et par rapport à ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya des nouveaux
véhicules sur le site mais aussi des
anciens véhicules quand l'entretien
l'employé un très fort attachement par
rapport à ça ça monte l'implication du
père semaine et tout le savoir-faire
qu'on a au sein barcus une manière aussi
de se faire un nom particulièrement
auprès du grand public et des passionnés
le conservatoire devrait accueillir des
visiteurs à l'occasion d'événements en
attendant peut être un musée dans les
prochaines années